funny thing about this movie countdown
it was actually gonna be the next final
destination movie and they were like
well yeah its final destination but not
really so we're gonna call it countdown
now none of that is actually true I just
made it up but there's no way you would
have known that you could have believed
it was true because it's that possible
this movie is that ridiculous alright
let's review it and by review I mean
talk some [ __ ]
look what's review anyone Skynyrd review
this movie I feel like they're gonna
they're gonna say that reference that
sauce so the movie is countdown the
premise is there's this app that if you
download on your phone it'll tell you
how long you have before you die some
people's like 90 years some people it's
like two days when is our main
protagonist who's a nurse she gets the
app she's like oh I'm about to die she
figures out this app is real from
someone else who died and now she's like
oh I need to live and I'll shoot my
sister has the app now and she's gonna
die too so much death so much
destruction you may be saying to
yourself well why not just cheat that
cuz it's much more boring here if you
cheat death this invisible thing that's
not even there it just kind of goes out
and it just throws you on the ceiling on
the floor until you die don't cheat
death because the deaths are much more
boring than they are in final
destination so the thing about this
movie in a movie that's like oh people
are about to die how they're gonna die I
don't know but I'll but it's gonna be
interesting or at least bloodbath cool
you can go one of two routes you can
barely have any deaths whatsoever
because you're so confident that your
characters are going to carry the movie
that much or you just hide the light
character development in the shallow
characters with a bloodbath this movie
goes that first route when it probably
should have gone the second route this
movie lends itself to yes kind of
ripping off final destination but lends
itself to the premise of oh we got away
from death oh shoot now we're gonna die
anyway there's some interesting cool
things you could do with that and they
get sued for the rights but you know
interesting cool things you could do
with that this movie does none of it
this movies like will you just need to
figure out how did how to overcome this
obstacle this countdown clock that's on
my phone I'm gonna remember no one's
names in this man
remember no supporting characters names
in this movie but I will remember a
couple of supporting characters one of
which the dude who worked the cell phone
place and the other guy who was a priest
both of these people cell phone guy in
particular I'm like you're still in the
show right now that's what you were
doing this guy was funny in that bitter
kind of way like if you've ever worked
retail for any amount of time you get
him I have I get him god I got lucky
YouTube happened if YouTube didn't
happen I would be him accept the reality
of your situation that's the reality of
mine so other than a couple of those
supporting characters movie was kind of
a bore as much as that first glance it's
like oh no this is new territory because
it deals with apps that kill you and
that's relatively new for movies fact as
you walk out of this movie with that
well I've been there done that and it's
been done better as a thriller Kanade
didn't feel the thrills as a Gore movie
no as horror fun no I mean it's the
movies just kind of it's vanilla it's
plain it has some neat lower attach to
it so I feel like if they make a sequel
they could actually expand on the lore
and it could be better
number Annabelle Annabelle too was way
better Ouija Ouija to way better movies
not even that long I think it's like an
hour and 20 minutes or something like
that's a crazy short and quite frankly
it's just a boring mess so the fact that
it's an hour and 20 minutes and still
feels like - I'm gonna write this movie
up but before I do sponsorship this
video is brought to you by skill share
skill share is an online learning
community with thousands of classes
covering dozens of creative and
entrepreneurial skills classes an
illustration graphic design photography
creative writing animation fine art
music film and video not gonna lie I
think I keep taking these sponsorships
so I rattle off that list but they have
that more whether you want to feel your
curiosity creativity or even career
skill share has some skills to share as
it's always smart to cross-promote the
sponsorship and the video might I
suggest app development they have
classes on app development no killer
apps though those are not smart repeat
customers that's key you don't get
repeat customers with a killer app so
don't do that don't feel like this movie
so thank you to skill share for
sponsoring this video sign up the skills
share using the link in the description
get yourself
2-3 months of Skillshare an annual
membership to Skillshare cost less than
$10 a month because me personally I
don't think you should have to go into
an insane amount of debt to get skills I
don't so thank you to skill share for
sponsoring this video
ok countdown here's your countdown right
here I'm not gonna remember this movie
in t-minus one day yep already forgot
there it is one day before this movie
dies from my memory I so countdown
you're not gonna see it alright so Joker
have you seen it how many times
let's just be real at this point has it
gotten better as it gotten worse have
you thought about it do you have new
theories whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
liked what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
I'm not asking anything about this movie
countdown let's not waste each other's
time Joker